Vice President Mike Pence says the US
has run out of patience with North
Korea's nuclear ambitions pence came as
close as he could overnight to stepping
onto North Korean territory he visited
the heavily guarded demilitarized zone
separating north and south korea and
said quote all options are on the table
vice president pence arrived in South
Korea just hours after the latest North
Korean missile test fizzled a former
British Foreign Secretary says a u.s.
cyber attack may have played a role in
the failure
Adriana Diaz is following the Korean
standoff from Beijing but first let's go
to chip Reed at the White House chip
good morning well good morning the White
House is sending a message to its allies
and to Pyongyang that North Korea is a
top foreign policy priority vice
president pence reinforced that message
with an unannounced trip to North Korea
to the Demilitarized Zone where he
pointed to recent military action to
highlight America's resolve if China is
unable to deal with North Korea the
United States and our allies will
standing with the acting president of
South Korea vice president Mike Pence
offered a warning to the north the world
witnessed the strength and resolve of
our new president in actions taken in
Syria and Afghanistan North Korea would
do well not to test his resolve the
administration is hoping North Korean
leaders were watching when the u.s.
launched a recent airstrike on a Syrian
airfield in response to a chemical gas
attack and when the u.s. dropped the 11
ton mother of all bombs on Isis in
Afghanistan earlier in the day vice
president pence stood in the
Demilitarized Zone just feet away from
the border of the isolated nation the
era of strategic patience is opened
President Trump has made it clear that
the patience of the United States and
our allies in this region has run out
celebrating Easter weekend in Palm Beach
President Trump commented via tweet
implying that China was helping pressure
their neighbor North Korea quote why
would I call China a currency
manipulator when they are working with
us on the North Korean problem we will
see what happens the administration's
plan is to increase pressure on the
North Koreans diplomatically working
mainly with China additional sanctions
on the regime are a possibility as well
as the use of military force this is a
situation that just can't continue
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
said the u.s. was working with allies to
avoid war it's time for us to undertake
all actions we can short of a military
option to try to resolve this peacefully
vice president Pence is just the latest
top administration official to visit the
region's Secretary of Defense mattis and
Secretary of State Tillerson have also
been there recently it's all part of the
president's balancing act of reassuring
allies while showing strength to North
Korea Gayle chip thank you